have you seen these images coming out of
Azerbaijan a hundred thousand people
have fled their homes let me show you on
the map why this has happened we're
talking about a region up here it's
called the Caucasus these two countries
Azerbaijan in Armenia there's been a lot
of tension between these two about
borders which is why you have all these
enclaves one of these borders is right
here the region of nagoro karabakh
ethnic Armenians have lived here for
decades and have been trying to make
their own state within Azerbaijan
Azerbaijan has tried to drive them out
for decades but Russia it was just right
up here has been the one kind of keeping
the Peace Keeping stability between the
two but Russia has turned its attention
towards its warn Ukraine so Azerbaijan
with the support of their neighbor
turkey has kicked out almost everyone in
this enclave and pushed them into
Armenia and that's what we're looking at
in this imagery all of this is a sign of
Russia's waning influence in the
Caucasus and an increase of turkey's
influence there if you want to better
understand International politics follow
for more